[Música]
i
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola
hoy quiero invitarlos a que pensemos en
la multiplicidad del ser
todo eso que nos hace seres diversos
múltiples sensibles
que se manifiestan de muchas formas
caóticos
si pensamos los niños los niños no
tienen filtros
a diferencia de unos años después
empezamos a montarnos cantar en un
proceso como de cuaje pero cuando somos
niños un niño no está pensando si la
persona que está allá
tiene una identidad sexual que está bien
o mal tampoco piensa así cómo se mueven
como habla cómo se expresa está bien o
mal si lo están viendo bien o no
si está generando algo en los demás
simplemente es
cuando yo era niño
era un poco raro
edifica que lo sigo siendo pero bueno
que el niño no es particular
yo llegaba del colegio
estoy a mi casa para hacer tareas teoría
no las hacía encerrada en mi cuarto en
esa época
algunos jugaban nintendo atar y game boy
tamagotchi no no me interesaban
y encerrado en mi cuarto y para mí era
un espacio de escape
a un espacio de libertad
para expresarme para simplemente ser
empecé a escribir mis primeras canciones
contando melodías en la cabeza
luego las hembras así en el computador
la se encallaba el paint las imprimía
me disfrazaba con la ropa linda humana y
creado personajes
como en esa época no teníamos youtube
para buscar los artistas que nos
gustaban sacaban los leyes el disco de
mi papá el michael jackson se robaba los
ponía y empezar a imitar los pasos de
michael jackson
pasan los años y vamos entrando en una
especie de proceso de montarnos de
pertenecer
de cuajar
para que nos vean como nos quieren ver
cuando llegó este man
que se alter ego ese personaje
de alguna manera recordé todo eso es que
me hacía feliz cuando era niño
empezaron a salir esa multiplicidad de
sensibilidades de artes que se mezclaban
el teatro el canto la actuación pero
sobre todo esa posibilidad de ser
diverso
de explotar eso a través de algo y no
solamente eran los múltiples manes desde
el yo sino fue un proceso realmente
había más males quiero decir otras manos
que me acompañaban me complementaban
entonces pensé así mis primeras
canciones porque no soy músico de
academia ni ni llegué a la academia
estudiando un instrumento sino botando
melodías y mi hermano que estudiaba
música en ese momento se convirtió en mi
mano derecha para empezar todo esto y no
solo mi hermano sino diferentes personas
otros amigos que estudiaron al mismo
tiempo que estaban empezando a construir
también una carrera la música pero no
sólo eso otras personas que empezaban a
ayudarme a hacer toda la escenografía de
los vídeos para crear toda esta
multiplicidad
manifestaciones
y proponerles un ejercicio y es que
recordemos cada una los que están acá
los que nos están viendo también a
través del streaming
recordemos todo eso
llegamos en particular de nosotros
cuando éramos niños y que de pronto
ahora no lo tenemos o que lo tenemos muy
guardado recordemos lo un momento
debo de pensar eso
pensemos en cómo podemos usar eso para
nuestros proyectos
para la creación la construcción de
nuestra identidad porque siempre estamos
construyendo más
somos seres caóticos somos seres con
rarezas con imperfecciones y eso es lo
más bonito del ser humano ser imperfecto
porque eso es lo que luego uno puede
potencializar en su arte y en la
construcción de su identidad
hoy los invito a que hagamos de eso algo
caótico a que realmente unos con otros
para poder aceptarnos a nosotros mismos
aceptemos esas imperfecciones y realizas
de los demás
[Aplausos]
no
[Música]
y tú y tú a tú
hay cosas en la vida que no se pueden
cambiar
me siento se ordena a la naturaleza pero
yo prefiero estar en un lugar donde será
muy natural
gatica de pensar
o no
[Música]
y
o
e
cómo
y
[Aplausos]
él
e